what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to poo sheisty ugly
featuring gucci mane before i start
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and bring that notification bell that
way you're going to be notified of my
daily videos
um while you're at it
leave a comment let me know if you like
these type of videos i haven't been
doing the music reactions as much lately
so if you like them
let a girl know alright
[Music]
now i hear
you play boys
[Music]
[Music]
okay so he's just letting you know um
that he's a tough guy
he
and is he's not afraid to let it get
ugly i thought this was gonna be a song
about like self-esteem you know like
sometimes i feel ugly inside but no
he's letting you know this [ __ ] can get
ugly
and the music video is clearly showing
that he's got hoes he's not afraid to
show him oh
[Music]
there's a couple themes um
one is definitely that the money has
helped him attain
females
for sure um the other thing
is that he's not afraid to empty his
clip so i think a clip is like a part of
a gun that holds the bullets so if it's
empty that means he's firing shots left
and right
[Music]
[Music]
so this is an interesting setup wait i
want to scroll back for a second
in these
in these music videos who designs the
furniture
i'm not i'm not an artist i'm i don't do
interior design but you got all this
money clearly like you're showing off
all the money invest in an interior
designer
[Music]
and like these girls
all this money if you can't afford a
shirt that fits
call me old-fashioned like
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay so he's saying that he
he doesn't give out his trust to just
anyone
and there's not really much left that he
has to give he says he can't change it i
think you can with some you know some
therapy self-development but we all make
choices in life okay gucci
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so he said i respect the girls that used
to
f with me when i was nothing
i don't clearly he doesn't have enough
respect for them you know to call them
by their names not call them hoes
put a ring on it but you know he
he's still thankful you know
oh shoot
okay i think that was that um i'm gonna
rank this song like a one out of five
there was no there's no theme of
goodness you know nothing i could really
take away from it
so yeah one out of five
anyways
don't forget to subscribe
ring that notification bell i'll talk to
you guys next